hi everyone Sal Khan here from Khan
Academy welcome to our daily homeroom
for those of y'all who are new to this
this is something that we started doing
a few weeks ago as we started seeing the
math school closures and obviously Khan
Academy were not-for-profit with a
mission of providing a free world-class
education for anyone anywhere and we
realized that as the schools were
closing we wanted to put our resources
together so that it could be as useful
as possible for you the student the
teacher the parent and we also wanted to
provide more supports especially since
all of us are now socially distanced so
that we can feel connected so that we
can answer each other's questions so
that we can support each other and so
we've been running teacher webinars
parent webinars and we have been doing
this daily homeroom which is just a way
to connect talk about whatever y'all
have on your mind and to have
interesting guests now before we get
into the the meat of the homeroom so to
speak
I will say what I always say a reminder
that we are not-for-profit we are funded
with philanthropic donations we were
running at a deficit even before this
kovat crisis hit and now our traffic is
about 2.5 3x of what it typically is and
so our costs have gone more and we want
to provide more supports so if you are
in a position to do so please think
about donating to Khan Academy I do want
to give special thanks to several
corporate partners who have stepped up
in the last few weeks really in record
time and to help Khan Academy with this
effort a Bank of America
Novartis google.org AT&T and of course
there's many other longtime supporters
but we still need more help we're still
digging into our reserves in order to
stay operational so now that I've given
you my my plug I want to introduce our
guest you know we've had a lot of
questions about all things academic how
do we keep learning in math how do we
keep learning in the in the humanities
and how do you keep learning in foreign
language and so I have today Luis von
Ahn an old friend of mine who is the
founder CEO of duolingo many of y'all
might be familiar it's a place that's an
app or you can learn languages for free
but I don't lease maybe you're more
qualified than I am
tell me about what y'all do at the
building go well thank you for having me
Sal and thank you for this initiative
it's great that you guys are doing it
well it doesn't mean we teach languages
that's the main thing we do you can
either do it online in a computer at
duolingo com or you can download an
iPhone app or an Android app it's free
to learn it's entirely free to learn and
you can learn as much as you want for
free and the other thing is that it we
spend a lot of time making sure that
it's fun to learn a language with
duolingo so it feels a lot like you're
playing a game when when you're learning
on duolingo we've worked really hard on
that and what are you as I can see we're
seeing some screenshots now from
duolingo and Louise what are what are
you seeing in this I guess how are
people using duolingo before was it
being integrated with your kind of
traditional you know high school classes
and languages whereas it mainly adults
who are trying to learn maybe for a
business trip and then how are you
seeing the usage change since since the
crisis began yeah I mean we've had we
have we have a ton of users I mean we
have well over 300 million users
worldwide the its it's all over the
place I mean with the age range is from
you know six seven years old to 90 some
years old there's as far as we know we
don't know for a fact because we don't
really track this anybody really can use
duolingo but as far as we know about 25
percent of language classrooms in the
u.s. used to link one one way or another
so we do have a lot of student users but
we also have a lot of adult users who
are just you know wanting to improve on
their high school French or something
the since this since everybody's been
staying at home we've seen our usage go
up quite a bit and you know our user
base is pretty global only about twenty
percent of our users are in the United
States and one thing that's been
interesting is pretty much every country
as soon as they apply their their social
distancing measures we see traffic
increase about one or two days after
that and it depends on the country in
some countries it has more than doubled
in some countries it has gone up by
fifty percent that kind of depends on
the country but we've seen that the
first country obviously where we saw
that was China about three months ago we
basically the traffic in China doubled
and it's it remained like that
um so you know I don't know what that
means a lot of China's back to normal or
mostly normal yeah our traffic remains
essentially you know twice what it was
before and what do you think is
underlying that is let's say China for
example I am curious what language are
folks learning is in all languages is it
English and then what do you think is
the motivation people are like I'm home
I might as well do something productive
or are there other other motivations um
I think I think the motivations I think
there's there's both I think there's
there's a lot of kids who had to be in
school and and now are home and they're
trying to figure out how to you know how
to learn whatever they used to be
learning and a lot of teachers are
telling to use duolingo but there's also
people who are just bored at home and
you know it used to be the case that
they used to go to a restaurant now that
time is being occupied for something
else and they think that you know
improving their lives is an important
thing so I think a lot of people are
doing that in terms of what languages
people are learning it really depends on
the country in in most non-english
speaking countries people are learning
English that's the main language that
the most everybody is learning in the
United States the biggest language is
Spanish second is French
then German then Japanese and then it
tapers off quite a bit
um we do offer from in the u.s. you know
from English you can learn about 35
languages on duolingo but you know some
of the smaller ones you can learn high
Valyrian from Game of Thrones you can
learn you know Esperanto you can learn a
lot of kind of some of the smaller
languages but but those are not too many
people are learning those compared to
Spanish for example it's high Valyrian a
fully fleshed out language that like we
could have a rich conversation in I I
think so I think there's a lot of
strange things I think it has a lot of
different words for things like sward or
it stuff like that yes words for I so I
guess let me tell you something else
which I don't know what this says about
the world but um during you know when
the seasons were on for Game of Thrones
there were more people learning high
Valyrian on duolingo and there were
people learning Irish for example or
Scottish which I don't know what this is
about the world but that was the case
fascinating fascinating and what's your
sense you know now there's a lot of
parents and adults you know I have
always had aspirations to get better at
certain languages
learn certain languages what's your
general advice there I guess this advice
would carry over if we weren't in this
crisis situation where do you think
duolingo is really strong and then where
would you what would you supplement that
with if you really were trying to you
know get get conversational in Spanish
or English or some other language yeah I
mean I think we'll the first thing to
know about learning a language is that
um it takes a while you know there's a
lot of you know fake news marketing out
builets as you can get fluent in the
language in nine days or whatever this
is just not true it'll it'll take years
to get really fluent in a language you
can get a lot of progress in a few
months but if you really really want to
get very advanced in language takes
yours so the first thing I think you got
to do is build a habit as with most
everything else so if you if you build a
habit you know spend 15-20 minutes a day
using duolingo and you do it over a long
period of time you get quite good at it
you know things I would recommend once
you get once you get to a point where
you've done about half the duelling of
course or maybe a little more than that
um I would recommend watching you know
you can watch Netflix in you know
Spanish or shows in other languages I
would recommend watching those a lot of
times you can watch them with the
subtitles now try washing them with the
subtitles in the learning not in English
because then you just want the attention
but if you watch with the subtitles in
Spanish too I think that's a pretty good
way to get much better you know after
you do duolingo but what you do you know
you can't quite start by doing that
because it's pretty hard to understand
the things yeah and I remember that I
used to watch these uh Spanish dramas
when I was trying to learn Spanish it is
it is it is effective and that you've
touched on some questions we were you
know from Instagram Sanath underscore
seven asks how do you establish a habit
of learning every day you just mentioned
the importance of habit what what do you
recommend for people to who are trying
that yeah well one of the important
things I think is to do it every day at
the same time that helps if you just for
example personally the way I do it is
basically as soon as I wake up kind of
the first thing I do is
do my duolingo if you if you pair it
with something else it's like well I'll
do it right after I brush my teeth or
I'll do it right after lunch and do it
at the same time every day that that
seems to really help another thing is
that um it's the first maybe 20 ish days
that really matter I mean we see it we
see it in our data if if we can get you
to come back consistently for about 20
days then you'll come back to duolingo
for very long periods of time so so you
just kind of try to stick to it for
about 20 days I said you have some
questions for you in particular you know
from YouTube Reverend hogwash hiss
asking how many languages does Luis
speak and you just mentioned that you
you are still learning languages so I'll
extend that not only how many do you
speak but what are you trying to learn
right now okay I will say I am I am
relatively good at English I am
relatively good expand it about the same
as English in Spanish I'm pretty good at
Portuguese not quite as good as as
English but almost and then I am
intermediate beginner in French the
pronunciation is my is my nemesis for
French and what are you trying to learn
right now you mentioned you you still
have visited French I'm who in French
that's that's the one I start started
about a few months ago I started with
French after I learned Portuguese I
started with French a few months ago
fascinating and people are asking a cut
several folks this from Instagram Baker
girl 325 asks why did you create
duolingo wow that's a great question um
you know I started duolingo it wasn't
just me I mean there's a whole team of
people that works on it but at the
beginning there were two of us me and my
co-founder his name is Severin and his
last name is hacker by the way which is
just crazy but we we started it and the
idea was that we wanted to do something
that would give equal access to
education to everybody I mean it's
something you know about Sal in
particular for us we're both neither
forces from the US we both had to learn
English when we were growing up and
English has opened so many doors for us
I mean we were able to come to the
United States come to college etc and we
knew that in most countries in the world
non-english speaking countries of the
world knowledge of English
can increase your income potential by
sometimes as much as a hundred percent
so you can basically double your income
if you know English so we knew that but
at the same time most of the ways there
were to learn languages were pretty
expensive at the time so what we wanted
to do was to make a way to learn
languages that was going to be freaky
and in particular we wanted to
concentrate on English it turns out that
you know English is a big language for
us but now we've basically decided to
teach pretty much every language we're
not there yet there are 6000 languages
and we only teach 35 but we're working
on it and you mentioned you're free and
you know this is something we have in
common and we have you know slightly
different models we're philanthropic we
funded but it is an interesting question
I think a couple people referring to it
so how do you all exist how do you make
money
yeah my mission was always to for
anybody to be able to learn the language
entirely for free on duolingo and you
know the question is how we're gonna
make money what we decided to do is kind
of this double thing that is similar to
how for example Spotify it makes money
um you can fully learn a language and
duolingo
but after every lesson you have to watch
a very short ad that's you know usually
just a static image sometimes is about a
you know a couple of seconds where you
have to watch an ad so basically watch
ads that's one way we make money but if
you don't want to watch the ads you can
also pay to subscribe to do a link on
that turns off the ads so it's one of
those two ways and yeah only three
percent of our users pay us to to turn
off the ads the other 97% are using it
entirely for free yeah this is an
important thing to bring up because you
have to figure you know whether whether
your run is a not for profit or for
profit there's some way yeah you know a
lot of folks I think imagine Khan
Academy still salan a class at some
place or where they imagine Luis and
you're your co-founder Severin hacker
which is an incredible name I mean to
start a company with that you know it's
just you but these you know it costs a
lot of resources and so you have to
figure out some way to make it work
while still being true to your mission
which I think y'all are doing a great
job so here's a question I don't know
this would fall under your domain loose
but maybe you have a point of view I I
could try to attempt as well from
YouTube
Ashutosh Tiwari who's actually a regular
question
Oscar here says hello Luis and Sal how
do I overcome stuttering if you stutter
more if you stutter more in English I
don't know if this is something that
you'll even address or you have a point
of view on this Luise I it's not
something that we do with the app I
actually would not know how to become
how to overcome stuttering I myself
stutter a little bit um so if you have a
good idea so let me know yeah I'm not an
expert in it either I I have been known
to stutter every now and then one thing
that was interesting and I don't know if
this is related to stuttering but I
remember my first job this was at Oracle
I was a product manager and I had to go
to this training on public speaking and
what they did is they videotaped you
while you gave a speech and then when
you watched it every time you said um in
your speech you also had to say um and
everyone in the room said um and that
made me very conscientious of um I still
say it but you don't realize how much
you say words like um and I know every
language has its own version of I um not
only that I mean you get so I before
this I was a professor in computer
science and on my first year somebody
told me that I should videotape myself
in every lecture and then watch myself
first of all was extremely painful and
secondly you know you start annotating
things like you know how many times you
say um for me one of the bad things I
used to I used the word like a lot that
was that was pretty bad and I think
there actually helped for sure for sure
I and it is a painful experience I try
not to even watch these live students
afterwards so from YouTube the Disney
and travel guy asks any tips to learn
Spanish I'm trying to learn Spanish on
duolingo and I really want to be fluent
so one should what should the Disney and
travel guy do here Louise um well keep
at it like I said it takes a while to
become fluent in a language and I would
say once you once you've gotten some of
the basics which you know if you're
maybe down to the middle of the duolingo
course or or three-quarters down the
dual
you know I will say something that I
said before in this I would try starting
watching some Netflix shows in Spanish
there's some really good ones I
particularly like the money heist but
there are others and and watch it and if
you can if it's too hard for you try
maybe children's show in Spanish
children's shows in Spanish they're a
little easier and also tried turning on
the subtitling what but this are
probably in Spanish
that should help yeah and what do you
say if someone wants to become fluent
what's your sense of immersion or some
version you know if you can't travel to
the country you know some version of
immersion like getting on video chats
with folks or something like that what
is that all of that helps there's a
problem with it
um it is most people have too much
social anxiety to get on video chats
with random strangers in a language that
they're not very good at so you know if
you're able to overcome that that's
that's a pretty good solution but I
think a lot of people are just it's just
too much social pressure for them so in
that case you know I don't I don't think
that's absolutely necessary I think you
can get pretty far by just using tools
like duolingo and you know watching TV
shows and stuff like that cool so if you
can obviously do a lingo the the Netflix
in Spanish or whatever that those are
great things that anyone can do like
starting now and then if if you can
overcome the social pressure maybe get
on some I know there are I don't even I
don't have no their names but there's
there's ways that you can get connected
with folks and get you know talk to live
people and the other languages so it's
interesting so yeah this is a question I
guess for both of us from Instagram
manfried dot gone more asks does the
speed at which you learn affect the
retention of knowledge for language or
math so you could take the language side
or if you have a point of view on the
math side do you think there are certain
people who are better at languages than
others or do you think it's it's just in
our minds you know there's a I do think
there are certain people who are a
little better than others there's
actually there's been there's been
research about that you know some of it
has to do with general
halogens but actually one of the biggest
things is just being okay sounding not
so smart if you're okay with that I
think you're better at learning
languages because one of the biggest
things in that that helps you learn
languages faster is if you start
speaking the sooner you start basically
able to vocalize and say stuff the
better this is why with duolingo we
recommend that whenever you're doing the
dueling exercises you just try to mouth
them just like kind of vocalize
everything that you're seeing the sooner
see the sooner you start being able to
talk to others the better you get and so
one of the ways in which some people are
better at learning languages is they
just basically don't care as much about
sounding you know broken and that's so
what you're really saying is you know we
talk a lot about things like mindset and
growth mindset here at Khan Academy and
you're really making the same point that
people who are more comfortable putting
themselves out there they're not afraid
to fail that those folks in general are
going to grow more Virts just the people
are like oh I don't sound intelligent in
this language yet let me just kind of
keep preparing their their their
preparations and I think the exact same
thing is in math you know I think people
are quick to label themselves or others
as slow learners or fast learners you
might see the kid in in your class and
she's always getting the A's and you're
always getting a few points less oh
maybe she's a fast learner but the
reality is she was probably the person
who's always pushing stepping out of her
comfort zone willing to get questions
wrong if she gets the question wrong
she'll reflect on it and she's always
trying to draw connections between
things I think probably the same thing
is true in languages is math is the more
associations you can make with something
the more it'll it'll be fluent to you
the more it'll it'll come to your you
know I'm not a expert at this but at
least on experience and observing others
and we've interface with a lot of the
experts on you know things like grit and
girls mine said that that really seems
to be the the best choral int so let's
see you agree from Instagram Sam I 804
asks how can I make the process of
learning a language fun and and I'm
assuming above and beyond using the fun
duolingo or our
even more fun the main way is by using
two illegal I mean this is we spend a
lot of effort making duolingo as fun as
possible there's a lot of features in
duolingo that make it more fun for
example we have these leaderboards with
leagues where the idea is that whenever
you join duolingo you get paired with
you know it's not paired grouped with
about 50 other people who who started
around the same time as you and for the
next week you get to see who gets more
experience points and the top 10 people
in that group of 50 move on to the next
league so everybody starts in the bronze
League then the top ten move on to the
silver league then next week the top ten
move on to the gold League and then we
have a bunch of leaves like that so that
competition actually makes makes the app
significantly more fun so I think that's
one thing another thing that we really
really believe in is that um with
duolingo you can learn you know in two
to three minute segments so anytime you
basically you know are waiting for
something for two minutes or something
you can just get in a little bit of
duolingo and I think that's that's
another way if you just parse it out
into smaller chunks that helps it's
great and on Facebook a question from a
Margo McGinnis oh hi Margo I know Margo
my kids need to catch up with sixth
grade Spanish for a new school over the
summer starting from scratch any tips
well down the dueling it depends you
know for sure download duolingo I would
say try to get them you know other tips
that we the things that we hear other
than duolingo and maybe watching some
Netflix in Spanish is try reading the
news in Spanish there's also some
podcasts by the way we have a podcast
there's the duolingo Spanish podcast but
there's others and you can try to listen
to some podcasts some of them are pretty
fun the duolingo in particular one the
duolingo podcast is basically real
stories of people from Latin America
about about stuff you know like soccer
players and stuff like that that are in
very slow Spanish and that that helps
you yeah what
one of my ideas just speaking generally
about about learning languages I have
memories of you know my my family's
original tongue is Bengali and but my
mom also also spoke you know Hindi and
/or due to some of our friends and you
know growing up in New Orleans there's
no immersion for that but she I would
hear her conversations with her friends
and especially when she was saying
something really juicy that wasn't meant
for my ears it would be either in
bengali indi slash or do and that's how
I got my functional brain definitely
things I understand you got through
understanding right right your brain
wants to understand what what it's not
allowed to understand but yeah so yeah I
could imagine actually marker situation
a lot of parents are trying to figure
out you know it might be a situation
like that that you're transitioning in
school or obviously school's out can we
can you leverage you know we've been
advocating how you can use the remainder
of the school year and even the summer
to keep learning in Spanish I started in
math but obviously the same thing can
happen in in Spanish or languages or
other subjects so other questions here a
few people are asking you Luis what was
your original tongue Spanish I'm
assuming I am I am a native Spanish
speaker yes where did you grow up I grew
up in Guatemala yes right underneath
Mexico that's where it is and and so
these other languages that you've
learned or learning like Portuguese and
French this is just out of interest or
is it do you have a lot of friends you
travel a lot to those regions
um it's not of interest I mean I you
know I figured I should learn some
languages given that I am the CEO of
duolingo so yes what it is out of
interest in those languages right great
well I think we've you've covered a lot
of this god asks how many languages do
you offer to learn I think it was a 35
35 from English in 135 languages yeah
and here's a question from YouTube
Nikhil go vendor asks if someone has a
learning disability
they're asking both Khan Academy and
duolingo how it's suited to help any
thoughts there Louise
depends on what learning disability but
I think we know of a lot of people who
have all kinds of different learning
disabilities who very successfully use
duolingo we know you know we try to make
the app as accessible as possible
and yeah we know for example we know a
lot of people with dyslexia that
successfully use duolingo you can turn
off certain exercise types and and that
seems to help so it depending on the
learning disability I think it it can
work pretty well yeah we see a similar
situation on the Khan Academy side that
we haven't done any any focus studies
first for many learning disabilities but
to your point we're trying to make it as
accessible as possible and then we've
anecdotally heard for certain students
maybe with ADHD or dyslexia or someplace
on the Asperger's spectrum
in certain cases it you know being able
to work at your own pace
slow down things speed things up get
immediate feedback on exercises things
like that which is you know true of both
of our platforms and and other online
platforms that that sometimes can can be
helpful but I think there's probably a
lot more research to be had well Louise
thanks for joining us on and answering
these questions about language I think
this is an area where you know Khan
Academy I get a lot of questions when is
Khan Academy going to teach language and
you know we have kind of ketamine in
other languages but I always say there's
no need for us to do it there's duolingo
so you got to do a lingo and figure out
that so so yeah keep keep doing the
amazing work y'all do know and thank you
and thank you for doing this and for all
the amazing work we're huge fans of Khan
Academy here likewise thank you so so
everyone that's I think there's a couple
of other questions that y'all are asking
generally but I will say you know we're
doing this every day and I think we're
coming up to that the half hour but you
know keep your questions going if I
can't get them in over over today over
the next few days and I will try to
answer them in future days but as I
mentioned this is just a forum for all
of us to stay in touch stay connected
during the school closures talk about
things that might be relevant for
getting you through the school closures
or
that might just be interesting since
we're all socially distanced now expect
over the next few weeks we will have
many other interesting guests like Luis
to talk about anything from how you
might try to tackle a certain subject
how you might try to stay just happy and
content in this otherwise stressful
period or things about how you'd be
creative at home or what's what's the
state of the economy I'll also put my
plug in again
reminder that we are not-for-profit if
you are in a position to do so please
think about donating to Khan Academy we
are running at a deficit especially
given all of the traffic and and the use
of the resources because of this crisis
so I'll let you all go thank you for
coming to the homeroom livestream today
I actually have my daughter with me she
didn't want to she said can I show you
the she's right here
let me see if I can she's ignoring me
what no she's got headphones on but yeah
she's she was my special guest I wanted
her to be in the live stream with me but
she didn't want to but I'll let you all
go and I'll see you tomorrow stay stay
stay stay healthy
you